[Música]
a
hola y bienvenidos a europa y el
programa de actualidad europea de france
24 en español yo soy esther herrera caro
desde el parlamento europeo en bruselas
es un placer saludarles en el programa
de hoy hablamos de siria y de afganistán
dos países que han estado en el foco
mediático pero de los que ahora se habla
mucho menos en siria sigue el conflicto
recientemente se ha celebrado una
conferencia de donantes para el país con
más de 6 mil millones de euros
comprometidos por otra parte en
afganistán los talibanes se aferran al
poder siguen con su deriva autoritaria
con normas que obligan de nuevo a las
mujeres a llevar al burka hay esperanza
para estos países lo analizamos con
nuestras invitadas las eurodiputadas del
grupo socialdemócrata mónica silvana
bienvenida a mónica buenos días muchas
gracias por invitarme igualmente y con
la eurodiputada del partido popular
europeo rosa estaràs bienvenida arrasa
muchas gracias es un placer un placer
tenerlos a las dos aquí por primera vez
además me gustaría empezar con una
pregunta que sería para las dos
recientemente se ha celebrado la
conferencia de donantes de siria en que
se han superado los estos seis mil
millones de euros de ayuda humanitaria
también para el país pero también para
los países vecinos es una medida
importante pero el país sigue colapsado
con este tipo de iniciativas suficientes
rosa bueno efectivamente creo que ya es
un logro que se haya realizado como
ponente permanente de ayuda humanitaria
de este parlamento estamos muy
preocupados desde que no se quite el
foco a otra de las grandes crisis
congeladas o las llamadas crisis
olvidadas siria afganistán se están
dentro de ellas por lo tanto primero es
muy importante que se haya realizado a
pesar de la terrible guerra en ucrania
es la sexta conferencia que se hace se
ha logrado recaudar más que más que las
anteriores más de 55 países y
organizaciones internacionales
y efectivamente llevamos desde la unión
europea siendo el mayor donante con más
de 27 mil 400 millones de euros puestos
puestos en solidaridad con siria pero
efectivamente quizás no son suficientes
pero lo importante es que se haya hecho
y que los ojos de la unión europea la
solidaridad europea siga estando
presente presente en síria hay un
problema de hambre tremendo 60 por
ciento de las personas que aún viven en
dentro del país tienen y de estar
solidaridad debe estar allí
pues si efectivamente la unión ha sido
diríamos locomotora en lo que ha sido la
ayuda europea en la ayuda cooperación a
siria llevan ya llevamos ya muchos años
de conflicto 15 millones de personas
desplazadas fuera y desplazadas dentro
con problemas de alimentación con
problemas de sanidad problemas de todo
tipo niños que no asisten al colegio
ayuda de emergencia supervivencia y por
lo tanto todas estas conferencias han
puesto el foco en que no debemos de
perder la mirada en poder enviar toda la
ayuda aumentar ya a siria y que llegue
donde tiene que llegar a través de todas
las organizaciones de naciones unidas
para que no se pierda ningún ningún euro
y llegue precisamente a las personas
efectivamente estas conferencias han
ayudado a que se crea una plataforma
permanente para que esos más de 6.000
millones lleguen y como he dicho pues
con esto es lo ha dicho también mónica
con estos 27 mil 400 millones de euros
desde
el año 2011 la unión europea se ha
convertido en el mayor donante de ayuda
humanitaria siria justamente nos estás
comentando que hay que poner el foco en
este conflicto pero hay riesgo ahora con
la guerra de ucrania lo has comentado de
que se convierte en un conflicto
congelado en que ahora mismo hay tantos
focos en el mundo que se olvide de seria
para eso estamos justamente el
parlamento para poner en agenda y que
estos temas lo ha dicho el alto
representante josep borrell que nuestra
preocupación tiene que seguir estando en
ciría la solidaridad tiene que estar
estando en siria y que la recaudación
sin precedentes que se está produciendo
para la apoyar obviamente a la terrible
crisis de ucrania tras la invasión rusa
no no se desvíen fondos ya comprometidos
para siria por lo tanto desde el
parlamento desde la comisión de
desarrollo y en mi carácter de ponente
permanente voy a estar insistiendo y
vigilando de que los fondos
comprometidos para sirias se ejecuten en
su totalidad y fundamentalmente se
ejecuten apoyando a las mujeres sirias
sabemos que 1 de cada 3 hogares siria
está gestionado con el sostén de familia
las mujeres haber perdido a sus maridos
a sus padres a sus hijos hombres muy
importante lo que comentas de las
mujeres esta es una pregunta para los
enfermos que muchas muchas guerras las
mujeres son especialmente vulnerables
lamentablemente según la onu más de 7
millones de mujeres y niñas necesitan
urgentemente servicios de salud sexual
reproductivos son extremadamente
vulnerables también a la violencia
sexual también en siria
las mujeres siguen siendo las grandes
olvidadas de los conflictos sí sin duda
las desigualdades de género las
dificultades para las mujeres se
incrementan siempre durante los
conflictos lo hemos visto en ucrania el
otro día tuvimos un encuentro con la
comisaria las mujeres son más del 80% de
las personas desplazadas y esas mujeres
muchas veces son víctimas de violaciones
de matrimonios en edad infantil
incluso se utiliza la violación como
forma de tortura por lo tanto hemos de
poner el acento en proteger a estas
mujeres tanto cuando se mueven dentro de
siria como cuando están desplazadas para
que no sufran o sean víctimas de
violaciones de trata blancas de
matrimonios forzados incluso hemos
tenido datos de informes como voices
from siria que habla de mujeres que se
casaron con funcionarios durante un
periodo corto de tiempo para poder pagar
servicios sexuales a cambio de
alimentación con lo cual tenemos que
poner el foco por eso estamos trabajando
desde la comisión de la mujer en
proteger a estas mujeres tanto dentro
como fuera para que se puedan prevenir y
evitar toda esa masacre porque al final
es una masacre utilizar la violación
como forma de tortura como proteger a
las mujeres si efectivamente como dice
rosa las mujeres son las más
perjudicadas en todo conflicto el
parlamento europeo hemos aprobado
recientemente el gap 3 donde exigimos
que toda la política exterior tenga un
impacto de género tenga esté incluida la
transversalidad de género creo que urge
en cooperación al desarrollo de ayuda
humanitaria
tener focos especializados en protección
de las mujeres estamos hablando de
violencia sexual de que en siria casi
hay medio millón
embarazada fruto de violencia por lo
tanto también aquí hay que hablar de
garantizar los derechos sexuales y
reproductivos
recientemente el tribunal europeo de
derechos humanos
en algunos informes estipula ya que la
negación del derecho al aborto también
es un símbolo de violencia hacia las
mujeres y de un conflicto tenemos que
pasar a otro lamentablemente afganistán
un país del que hemos hablado mucho la
tome tras la toma del poder de los
talibanes el pasado agosto la situación
ahora mismo es muy crítica la ayuda
humanitaria es muy necesaria en este
país pero hay temores de cómo pueden
utilizar los talibanes justamente este
ayuda
mónica si efectivamente está claro que
tras la retirada en agosto del año
pasado después de 20 años de avances
quizás para las mujeres fundamentalmente
que vivían en que vivían en afganistán
el régimen talibán está incumpliendo
hasta los más mínimos 5.5 acuerdos que
seas que se han firmado con la unión
europea para seguir garantizando la
ayuda humanitaria hemos congelado el
presupuesto de cooperación por supuesto
no queremos que el régimen talibán
gestione ni un solo euro
condicionalidad que puso la unión
europea pero la ayuda a la ayuda
humanitaria tiene que seguir estando y
ahora quizás con la última decisión que
agrava si cabe con la exigencia de
utilizar el burka como símbolo de
violencia a estas mujeres creo que la
situación agrava más allá la que existía
en haber prohibido la escolarización
secundaria o prohibir a las maestras
hacer su trabajo fundamentalmente en
educación el acceso a la educación a las
niñas y mujeres afganas
justamente ha estado haciendo referencia
a ahora que las mujeres en afganistán
tienen que volver a llevar este símbolo
de opresión que es el burka como como se
puede hacer de forma de que afganistán
no no tenga que regresar a 20 años atrás
es eso posible pues efectivamente es
verdad que llama la atención
poderosamente que después de 20 años de
mujeres afganas emprendedoras
protegiendo los derechos humanos pues
nos encontramos que lógicamente con un
régimen que conculca todos los derechos
humanos él burga es un símbolo pero
tenían que abrir el mes de marzo en la
escuela secundaria para las no han
abierto con la excusa de que están
buscando unos uniformes para las mujeres
además de no tener acceso a la educación
lo cual es muy grave les muchas veces
por la falta de alimentación se obliga a
estas mujeres a estar totalmente
volcadas dentro de la pobreza y han
cerrado la comisión de derechos humanos
y han sustituido la comisión de la mujer
por la comisión es que el nombre es
sonrojante pero bueno la comisión del
ministerio del vicio y la virtud con lo
cual han aprobado que cuando una mujer
tiene que tener movilidad de más de 72
kilómetros no lo puede hacer sin su
tutor con lo cual es una cosa es un
atropello a la dignidad de la mujer ya
todos los derechos humanos se ha
establecido un procedimiento de que si
alguna mujer incumple todo esto citarán
a su tutor primero irán a su casa luego
llevarán al tutor al ministerio y luego
lo encerraron en la cárcel con lo cual
pues
creo que la unión europea tiene ahí
mucho trabajo que hacer para que todas
las negociaciones sean siempre
respetando los derechos humanos
exigiendo que la mujer pueda tener
acceso a la educación y también al
trabajo a la libre circulación también
la libre circulación como os he dicho
con esto de los 72 kilómetros está en
entredicho o el derecho a las reuniones
pacíficas que tenemos muchísimo trabajo
por hacer pero creo que entre todos
podemos conseguir nunca reconocer este
régimen pero sí obligar a este régimen a
que cumpla la carta de derechos
fundamentales ya que se vuelvan a
restituir los derechos de las mujeres
muchas de las cuestiones que has dicho
rosas son una por una cosas que ya han
ocurrido en el pasado o sea afganistán
ya estuvo así hace 20 años hay de alguna
forma esperanza para que puedan cambiar
las cosas sólo la presión internacional
será suficiente efectivamente ahí me
abre la pregunta que nos hacemos todos y
qué prisas nos pone en un importante
dilema a la unión europea con la
condicionalidad que estamos exigiendo
estamos ayudando a las mujeres afganas o
la estamos dejando solas ante los
talibanes por lo tanto creo que también
esto nos pone en un dilema y nos abre
también la posibilidad de valorar
de reabrir los programas de cooperación
al desarrollo como son por ejemplo
emprendimiento para las mujeres como
sobre el fortalecimiento de la sociedad
civil pero hacerlo directamente a través
de las 25 organizaciones que trabajan en
el terreno ya no queremos ni un solo
euro para el régimen talibán pero
tenemos que ser lo suficientemente
innovadores y para poder que la
solidaridad llegue a las mujeres afganas
y no dejarlas solas ante el régimen
talibán esto quizás abre una nueva
puerta y así se lo hemos trasladado
tanto a la comisaria youtube line men
como al comisario lennar sí que por
cierto cabe destacar que el 80 por
ciento del presupuesto de eco de ayuda
humanitaria va destinado a trabajo con
las mujeres pero creo que es
insuficiente y que quizás haya que
plantarse reabrir programas de
cooperación al desarrollo también además
de ayuda humanitaria la comisaría está
abierta a ellos
bueno estrictamente estamos desde el
parlamento
esperanzados en que reabra al menos una
posibilidad de valorar y retomar algunos
de los proyectos que han sido congelados
tras la retirada de las tropas el pasado
mes de agosto pero hacerlo directamente
a través de las ongs que trabajan
en nuestros socios humanitarios que ya
digo son más de 25 organizaciones de una
solvencia demostrada ante ante la unión
europea pues muchísimas gracias rosa
mónica nos hemos quedado lamentablemente
sin tiempo pero hay que hablar de todos
estos temas a ustedes les esperamos en
el próximo programa de europa hoy
gracias por ver france24 en español
[Música]